so as we can hear from the protesters
there they're against corruption some
would argue that corruption is so
enmeshed in the sectarian confessional
political system can it be combatted
Without Really dismantling the whole
political system of the country I think
it's beyond corruption by far and what
the government currently is trying to do
is trying to suggest a few reforms
thinking that it's only a matter of
reforms and stopping any addition to
taxation which they've already admitted
to and retreated from that position but
I think it's important to take it into
context the current government got the
support of all but seven members of
parliament they got 121 votes out of a
possible 120 eight so this government
really represents all of the committee's
or all of the parties that are
represented in Parliament so what we're
looking at today the thousands hundreds
of thousands of people who've been
dropped protesting for the past three
days is just a huge shout of
discrediting the entire government and
the Parliament that created this
government so I think this goes beyond
corruption and just a few deals that
have instigated all those protests this
is a lack of trust in the system and the
calls go far beyond just corruption
they're calling for early elections
they're calling for a change of
government immediately they're calling
for an election of a new president plus
an accountability for all the funds that
have been stolen and that's why we have
85,000 billion dollars of that one of
the biggest amounts of debt versus GDP
so I believe what we see is a huge
realignment on political legitimacy can
the system survive and would early
elections change anything because
they'll be held along the exact same
sectarian confessional system and lines
yes it will change a lot this happened
back in 2005 the bath army was in
Lebanon
at the time as well as the intelligence
services the majority of Parliament was
elected by a law that was set up during
Syrian hegemony of Lebanon and yet in
2005 after the murder and assassination
of the Prime Minister late Prime
Minister Rafik Hariri what happened was
a huge movement the government was
toppled a technocratic government ruled
for exactly four months with the only
task of organizing new elections based
on the old law but the general direction
of the population shifted the balance in
Parliament to absolutely
anti Syrian regime and that was the
change which was known at the time as
the Cedar Revolution so I think the
precedence has happened there plus
historia but this is very difficult
silence again the protests are not aimed
at another army being asked to leave the
country
this is aimed as you yourself explained
against the very political class the
political system the parties that have
the support or the government that has
the support of almost all members of
parliament in order for it to be change
welcomed at decisions with the same
elections following the same old system
like any government in the world like
any system in the world the base of
power in any democracy lies with the
people and the people have spoken I
believe in this case and I think a lot
of political parties especially now with
the resignation of the first foreign
ministers and the tendering of the
potential resignation of the Prime
Minister and others we see there's a
massive shift and people feel those in
government feel they are losing all
public support around them this will
create a new reality in Lebanon and as
things show now the balance of powers
when they shift and public attitude
moves then there will be a new formation
of political power and legitimacy this
current government now cannot as it
seems offer anything substantial to
regain people's trust so even if the
political parties that are incumbent now
want to retain power they have to go
through
massive shift in the composition of the
type of government they create with the
faces currently known associated with
corruption associated with sectarianism
there is no way they can gather enough
legitimacy for the people in the street
to do them their only alternative is to
use violence which they try to exercise
on Friday evening and I believe those
are the elements that are being
challenged now is violence an option for
this government to retain its control or
does it go through a major revamp of its
policies and third do we go for a new
government that actually has legitimacy
with new faces those are the options of
the current political class versus the
shouts from the streets basically saying
we want to go far more and further than
just a taxation policy we want to go to
establish a new legitimate political
representation system in turn government
organized early elections and let's
reconstitute political power in this
country well I thank you for your
analysis on that mark Tao